bunch of questions for you is having
David as your lead actor like having a
cheat code in a video game
[Laughter]
yes yeah because he always he's always
add in um you he gives you a little bit
more than what you got on the page and I
don't mean in the fact of lines he'll
perform all the lines as beautifully as
written it's just um I guess as a raser
man I would probably tell you about
reggae music having his own beat and own
Cadence and its own Reverb that's what
David does so David adds a perfect
Reverb Reverb to what the other actor
might be doing which is just a regular
drum pattern can you talk a little bit
about actually working with him
specifically on set crafting his
performance how much is he like are you
just Whispering something like could you
talk about the way you collaborated
onset um yeah onset it was more so just
like these looks that we would have for
each other once our Shand I think sort
of got to that um it doesn't take very
long for you I think as a talented
director and as a talented actor to
realize you are in the presence of each
other and at that point it's just like
high five let's go win this game um you
know but it's
um he would always remind me you know
I'm from Trinidad he's a Nigerian guy
from London and here we are in America
you know getting to tell a story and I
think we owe it to our audience to
really truly give them our lens um you
know just the as sort of it's like why
not right why can't two black guys from
wherever the hell we are in this world
dream up something beautiful that no
one's ever seen before and I
think we would always take what our
writers gave us as sort of like this
beautiful Foundation right that that
told all of the Departments what to do
what to build what to make uh and we
would sort of insert or inject ourselves
in the middle there and just kind of say
what more could we give to this moment
you know and it was always an honest
thing if I said we were done David might
just look at me and I'll be like ah no
we're going again for him cuz there was
this unspoken look that there was
something else that he had in his spirit
that needed to get out one of the
reasons why Taylor Sheridan's shows I
think resonate with so many people is
that they're filmed on location they
look like a movie production but it's
being told on television but it also
means incredible challenges for the
Caston crew working in those
environments so can you talk about the
unique challenges that you faced over
episodes directed the state of Texas
being at the top of the list its weather
conditions um yeah it decided what we
would do when we would do it so you know
it took me I think five and a half
months to complete three of these
episodes um
and yeah you know it was just truly art
it isn't the kind of thing that you can
go in and say why aren't the stage
lights working you're like no there's a
storm moving over those planes and we
just can't shoot that right right now
the entire company is going to be in
danger so guess what we can't shoot that
right now um you know that is a creative
frustration I think for more so for
directors and actors who have sort of
gotten themselves prepared to come in
and film this right then and right now
but Texas makes you have to approach it
from the optimistic side um which is
what can we do right now um and a lot of
times we were we were faced with that
but yeah you start out a little tough
you start out being like man I hope
we're getting everything but then we'd
start watching these dailies and then
David would start calling me on the
weekend and I think by then we were
fully locked in you know we were fully
like man like you realize the
opportunity of what we have to tell here
and like and if these dailies are
looking like anything that we think they
are I think this is going to be great
for our audience talk a little bit about
you you directed three episodes how much
were you able to like block shoot and
film a bunch of things you know what I
mean like in the you weren't you weren't
really able to because in a traditional
block schedule does give you the ability
to you know sort of cheat a little bit
and make up sometime but yeah Texas
didn't really provide it was more like a
checkerboard schedule um because you
know we probably had a a a set that was
250 mile radius um you know we're in
Texas so it's huge man like so we're on
this ranch today we're on that ranch
tomorrow because there's a water feature
we are at this Ranch because we need to
do a railroad track set extension um but
at the same time it was a joy it was
like you know from what I do when every
time we do these projects and we have to
essentially give them or at some point
hand them over to the audience right the
audience is taking our judgment for it
that wow this is the best they could
have done in
2023 at telling this
story this was like Texas's way of
saying like well I'm going to show you
something else on top of that and this
is the joy of filming on location and
not having stage days talk a little bit
about editing the episodes and perhaps
how they changed in the editing room in
ways you didn't expect well for me the
edit process kind of started when the
strike started um I was actually in
Chicago getting ready to start a new
show and I I think we got paused after
four days so I came back to LA and I
realized post was just two and a half
minutes down the street so I went and it
was a joy because it was even a joy so
many us so many of us had been in that
Texas pressure cooker for 5 and have six
months that there were times just
honestly speaking even as directors you
know Christina and I may have a honesty
moment like God I hope I'm shooting
everything okay right because that's
also I you only have two directors here
so you're like God I hope I'm not like
doing the same thing over and over I
hope my whole episode isn't repetitive
and then you get a chance to go to post
where your editors have now taken this
in for the first time and there is
something there's some little light
email correspondence you get throughout
that says wow thanks for sending me this
seen or this is amazing or that's
amazing and so being able to go to post
also in a time after Co we in Co and a
lot of post was done remotely it was
just a blessing man to be able to get in
there and sort of actually get your
hands dirty and actually cut the film
with the editors that was a joy his life
is filled with like I it's I can't
believe that it's only eight episodes
because you know this anyway so what
were some of the things that you that
you learned about his life that really
surprised you I think overall is just
how tough it was to be him at the time
he was him um you know there weren't too
many black men with guns and badges to
have the guns at that time so I'm sure
that even uh him arresting certain
people is almost sort of
joval um in a sense so I I love that
part of his story that would have been a
part that I would have never gotten from
any of the history books just sort of
personally speaking what you as a person
that's sort of been granted Authority
you know by one powerful white man has
to go out and essentially tell everyone
else hey you got to listen to this guy
right he said I'm I'm him so I have to
be him but you know are people going to
listen so I thought that was that was
the most interesting part of the story
for me was kind of like here's a here's
a cop or here's a Lawman you know are we
just gonna come willingly uh talk a
little bit about Taylor Sheridan because
he definitely has a uh he has his hand
on the pulse in terms of what people are
want to watch so what do you think it is
about his storytelling that has so many
people you you know wanting to watch his
the stuff that he makes it's just
finding the human element in each script
I think a lot of people make scripts
that are like oh wait till the audience
sees this or wait till or this is going
to blow everyone's mind and I do believe
that even in the large universe that
Taylor has created it's you watch all of
them and you somehow feel like that's me
like I just watched lionist and I was
like hey man like I relate to this why
do I relate to this I am not a CIA
operative or I mean if I wasn't I'd be
like one of the most brilliant CIA
operativ ever right but I yeah you watch
it and there's something in there
there's something that and I don't know
if it's his time spent acting in this
business and maybe at a time that he
wanted to make suggestions and he
couldn't but I think he's definitely as
you said put his hand on the pulse
because it is now infiltrated our living
rooms and we are now feeling like oh
this is just capturing me and my family
this is you know
Yellowstone just happens to be about a
family from Queens or you know what not
we all see ourselves in a little bit of
something and I think bass Reeves is no
different I think you would be an
excellent CIA agent because you don't
look like uh every other what I would
consider to be an agent maybe this would
be the new show in the tale of sherid
Sheridan Universe right CIA right yeah
you know uh no but talk a little my last
question you obviously must have had an
amazing experience making the show
what's like a day that you will remember
forever in when you were on location
filming oh man it was actually my last
night there and we were shooting um a
thing in the um it's like the toughest
prison in the west um at the
time and the camaraderie had just gotten
so amazing at that point like we had I
don't know 60 something extras in this
prison scene and we you know my my first
ad went in there and he said you know
Damen wants you guys to be very loud and
you don't even care that bass Reeves
walks in you guys are the hardest
criminals out so in between each take it
was noisy this was like this 1800s
prison and we cut we were going again
and one of the extras just sort of got
up from his cot and he handed I don't
have it with me now but he handed me an
actual us Marshall's badge and he said
hey on behalf of the marshals in
Oklahoma we just wanted to say that
really proud of what you're doing here
and giving a chance to for us to even
take our history in again uh and he gave
me an official he's like you know you
kind of officially been kned man so I
guess I am an off-duty uh Marshall from
the state of Oklahoma uh that will that
has nothing or anything like that has
never happened to me while filming on a
show man so the fact that you know we
had extras that were just everyone was
feeling the energy everyone was feeling
the vibe feeling the emotion of what we
were doing and the magnitude of it and
to see it happen right there on set was
kind of cool on that note I got to stop
I'm just going to say I'm really looking
forward to seeing the rest of the
episodes and I wish you nothing but the
best y thank you so much I love the
shirt
man